encore un abruti sur youtube qui ne sait
pas quoi faire sûrement de son chômage
des vidéos sont vraiment à chier
pas étonnant de la part d'une marque
comme toi une forme de logique nul tu
racontes de la merde c'est qu'on ne sait
pas fort de puissance déjà qu'à déjà cas
j'en peux plus que tu peux toujours me
sur youtube c'est pas pour aller te voir
en spectacle
est-ce qu'il peut venir un spectacle
pour dire la fin et en plus ce nom
espèce d'abruti on sait que c'est des
complices tu crois qu'on a eu aussi con
que toi merci loïc d'avoir fait cette
petite sélection des commentaires sur la
chaîne je tâte à utiliser combien de
vidéos pour faire cette sélection l'a
beaucoup cette sélection vidéo d'accord
après j'imagine que ça t'a pris du temps
quand même
donc merci moi je prendre un peu plus de
temps pour encaisser ça se danse
personnes
[Musique]
salut pas évident de calmer son mental
de l'empêcher faire des projections de
gérer ses émotions ou tout simplement de
faire un petit peu le vide pour empêcher
notre cerveau de nous imposer ses
propres pensées
aujourd'hui on va parler de 0 mental et
je vais vous donner quelques astuces
pour empêcher votre mental de prendre le
contrôle et des décisions à votre place
loïc génériques
la vidéo d'aujourd'hui est sponsorisé
par l'application petit bambou c'est une
application très utile que vous allez
pouvoir utiliser je vous en reparlerai à
la fin de la vidéo
depuis quelques années le cerveau est
devenu un petit peu le roi en fait il
passionne il attire les gens et je suis
vraiment bien placé pour le savoir
mais ce dont nous avons peu parlé quand
même ces trois dernières années sur la
chaîne c'est que le cerveau ne doit pas
devenir un roi tyrannique
il doit pas être omnipotent
personnellement j'ai compris ça malgré
moi il ya plus d'une dizaine d'années et
je suis sûr que vous aussi vous avez
vécu ces moments où on est saoul et que
notre cerveau tourne à plein régime et
nous envoient des pensées qu'on n'a pas
forcément décider alors la logique il y
aura le premier panneau c'est pas nos 1
et puis de celui à marquer pour quoi
calmer le mental et tu peux faire copier
coller pourquoi reprendre le contrôle du
mental et bien pour reprendre simplement
le contrôle sur vos émotions sur vos
pensées et sur vos décisions quand vos
pensées s'organise
malgré vous complètement inconsciemment
alors elles sont remplies de billets qui
nous sont personnelles vos raisonnements
sont complètement trafic et vous
ressentez alors des émotions négatives
que vous n'aviez pas décider en amont
qu'est ce que c'est ce bordel
voilà ça c'est négatif vous subissez
alors complètement votre activité
mentale qui demande tout le temps à être
le centre du monde voici 5 astuces que
j'utilise depuis plus de dix ans pour
reprendre le contrôle
attendez à la une la deux la trois
la 4c celle ci et là 5 voilà c'est ça 5
la première astuce et de se reconnecter
à l'instant présent j'en avais parlé en
2016 sur la chaîne
c'est très important et en même temps ça
paraît évident quand le dit mais le fait
vous vraiment est ce que ça vous arrive
pas franchement de marcher dans la rue
dès dans le flux de vos pensées et de ne
pas avoir décidé ce que vous êtes en
train de penser vous vivez un petit peu
comme un rêve très que ça fait plaisir
d'aller manger chez thomas soir mais
après je vais les mains vides
bon bah j'ai rien ramené j'ai rien
ramener mais en même temps il va pas
faire la gueule quoi c'était à un moment
donné tu invites pas les gens en
espérant qu'ils amènent quelque chose
qui me fait une réflexion j'allais dire
il est relou il est toujours dans le
jugement
oui exactement ce genre de moments où on
a tout un fils de pensée qui se déroule
on l'a pas forcément décider
on sait pas pourquoi il est forcément
négatif comme ça et vous avez une
conclusion qui est complètement erronée
ça c'est quand vous n'êtes pas dans
l'instant présent vous subissez le
mental
l'objectif est donc de vous ramener
et maintenant pour faire ça il n'y a pas
trente mille solution c'est de dézoomer
c'est à dire complètement l' inverse de
sa logique pour pouvoir prendre du recul
et que tout devienne un peu plus nette
pour vous reconnecter au présent c'est
très simple vous vous posez juste la
question de temps en temps pourquoi je
suis en train de penser à ça à temps je
me calme est-ce que j'ai décidé vraiment
de penser à ça qu'est ce que j'en pense
vraiment si je l'analyse ou est-ce que
je suis maintenant où est ce que je vais
vous couper toutes les projections
futures dépenses et sur le futur vous
étiez au contraire en train de penser au
passé vous couper aussi je les trucs de
nostalgie ou de remords ou de regrets
juste vous observez un peu où vous êtes
vous observez vos émotions actuel et
vous observez à quoi vous pensiez et
vous vérifiez si vous aviez décidé ça
est en général non qui est juste le fait
de prendre ce recul là ça permet de vous
remettre dans le présent merci j'avais
que vous pouvez faire également qu'il va
vraiment vous aider à vous maintenir
dans l'instant présent c'est le soir
quand vous vous couchez et bien
simplement vous faites le film de votre
journée mais tranche par tranche morceau
de la journée par morceau de la journée
pour vous remémorer ce qui s'est passé
vous observez un peu ça vous observez ce
que vous pensiez ce que vous avez retenu
de tout ça et vous vous refaites
vraiment toute la journée ça va ancrer
cette journée dans le présent et vous ça
va vous éviter de vivre les journées en
mode flèche sans les voir passer
l'instant présent et un best-seller qui
existent vers l instant présent des
cartes au lait je vous recommande
vivement ce livre je mettrais un petit
bien la description astuces numéro 2 les
prises de décision alors là c'est pas
vraiment une astuce c'est surtout
l'importance de calme et de mental quand
votre mental est saturé par d'autres
informations soient que vous n'avez pas
décider soit des émotions un peu
négative soit des projections du passé
alors qu'il n'est plus capable de faire
une décision pure vraiment factuelle est
vraiment résonner le raisonnement n'est
pas stable et c'est pourquoi il faut un
peu purifiée tout ce qui est à la hausse
pour pouvoir observer les choses dans
leur globalité et faire les bons choix
l'exemple très simple c'est que si vous
devez faire des calculs un peu complexe
sur un grand tableau d'école vous allez
forcément nettoyer le câblo avant pour
le rendre bien neutre et faire vos
calculs et bien là imaginer que le
tableau soit déjà plein plein plein
plein plein plein plein plein de choses
et que vous
vié faire des calculs ce serait la
galère oui cette métaphore vous est
offerte par fabien olicard une astuce
néanmoins pour la prise de décision
c'est lorsque vous devez faire un choix
si jamais vous avez peur d'être
parasitée par l'émotionnel par exemple
vous avez un choix entre de travail et
vous connaissez bien les personnes et
vous savez pas trop vers quel taf
pencher bref tous les choix dont vous
n'êtes pas sûr d'avoir la maîtrise
émotionnelle ou cérébrale dans un
tableau vous mettez tous les avantages
du premier choix tous les avantages du
second choix et dans un second tableau
tous les désavantages du premier choix
et tous les désavantages du deuxième
choix et vous vous descendrez pour
regarder tout ça de manière factuelle et
vous allez pouvoir faire une prise de
décision comme si c'était le choix pour
quelqu'un d'autre
vous auriez sûrement fait ça si vous
n'étiez pas impliqué personnellement
vous auriez regarder les points un par
un et bien c'est ce que vous faites
quand vous remettez ça sous forme de
tableau n'hésitez pas à le faire c est
beaucoup
astuce 3 la méditation
évidemment je parle pas forcément da smr
néanmoins on n'a rien trouvé de mieux
pour calmer le mental que la méditation
c'est l'activité l'appui scène pour
faire un nettoyage de l'esprit et ça
doit être fait de manière quotidienne
sauf que on n'a jamais le temps pour le
faire
on n'a jamais le temps pour le faire
parce que on n'est pas assez dans
l'instant présent alors justement on va
parler un petit peu de l'importance de
méditer le but de la méditation c'est de
couper l'espèce de pilote automatique
qui via l' os donc on va aider le mental
a retrouvé de la sérénité
mais quand on dit ça à quelqu'un qui n'a
jamais dit et il fait je commence par
quoi et à chaque fois les réponses sont
très douteuse même moi quand j'essayais
d'expliquer à quelqu'un comment il
pourrait faire prendre est dit et je
sais pas bien répondre à ces questions
les questions c'est ben je pense à quoi
bon à rien précisément le but c'est de
faire le vide oui mais on ne peut pas
penser à rien alors oui c'est vrai en
fait il ya quelque chose de très simple
à faire c'est que quand vous méditer
vous mettez un petit peu dans un état de
relaxation et puis quand une pensée
apparaît c'est un petit peu comme un
nuage dans le ciel vous devez observer
cette pensée l'analyse est un petit peu
ne pas la juger en fait ne pas vous dire
pourquoi je pense à ça et c'est juste
voilà c'est ce qui est apparu
spontanément et vous essayer de la faire
passer comme si vous souffriez sur le
nuage c'est très facile de trouver des
images pour faire ça c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué de le faire au tout départ
c'est normal mais il ya des solutions
pour ça on va y revenir
un des buts ultimes de la méditation
c'est d'atteindre la pleine conscience
donc pour commencer avant même d'essayer
de méditer vérifiez que vous êtes dans
une pièce où vous ne serez pas dérangé
vous coupez votre téléphone vous couper
toute distraction possible si vous avez
faim manger avant ne fait pas ça quand
vous êtes trop fatigué parce que l'idée
c'est pas de s'endormir non plus en
méditant ça doit être un instant de
repos à vous rien qu'à vous dans quelque
chose une situation va dire au global
confortable la solution la plus simple
pour y arriver quand on est ultra
débutants débutants ou comme moi
confirmer ça reste la méditation guidée
alors c'est pas de l'hypnose ça pourrait
ressembler un petit peu à l'hypnose
conversationnelle mais c'est pas ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose de serein
où il ya quelqu'un qui doit guider notre
processus qui va nous donner des étapes
on va être aussi soutenue en général par
une musique et surtout il va nous
emmener sans qu'on ait à se soucier du
temps ou de qu'est ce que je fais
maintenant je sais pas trop quoi faire
dans cet état là voilà c'est la base de
la méditation guidée et c'est exactement
ce que fait l'application petit bambou
qui je vous l'avais dit sponsorise cette
vidéo personnellement je l'utilisent
depuis quasiment sa création il ya cinq
ans j'ai jamais arrêté de l'utiliser
depuis parce qu'elles offrent des
avantages certains déjà si une
application
donc j'ai mes statistiques donc ça
j'aime bien tu vois quand j'ai mes
statistiques sur quelque chose
voilà on va pas se mentir c'est un peu
dit elle est extrêmement cali tant dans
la forme que dans le fond les
méditations font en moyenne une dizaine
de minutes surtout dans les premières et
c'est très bien parce qu'on n'a pas
forcément tous une heure dans la journée
pour faire de la méditation
mais je le crois et je suis pas seul à
le croire il vaut mieux méditer un petit
peu tous les jours qu'une fois de temps
en temps surtout quand le temps
entendent à s'espacer de plus en plus
pour devenir jamais donc dans
l'application petit banc vous vous allez
trouver les méditation guidée qui font
en moyenne dix minutes les huit
premières sont offerts donc n'hésitez
pas à essayer pour voir aussi vous ce
que c'est directement
et puis les huit premières c'est
vraiment notre découvert donc si je
n'avais jamais méditer de votre vie ça
va être très cool et après pour ceux qui
veulent continuer ou avoir d'autres
méditation il ya des systèmes
d'abonnement qui sont mensuelles ou
annuelles je crois que ça commence à
partir de 4,99 par mois il me semble
rectification et 6,6 et passe à autre
chose qui je pense va vous intéresser
les auteurs et les voit d'ailleurs de
petits bambou donc des méditations
d'idées sont des experts dans leurs
domaines respectifs vous pouvez aller
sur le site de petits mangou
il ya un endroit où vous avez la liste
de tout le monde vous voyez leurs
visages vous voyez leur nom et surtout
vous voyez leur cv et quels sont les
méditations qu'ils ont créés dans
l'application
donc ça c'est cool c'est pas un truc qui
a été fait avec les pieds n'importe
comment ça a été fait avec les têtes et
avec le coeur
oui excellente question improvisé quand
est-ce qu'on organise sa routine de
méditation alors forcément au début un
petit peu comme à chaque fois qu'on veut
créer une nouvelle habitude dans sa vie
on est très motivés et donc peu importe
le moment mais avec le temps ça va être
dur de maintenir cette habitude parce
que dès qu'on la rate une fois on la
rate deux fois et puis après on ne
reprend pas il faut en moyenne 66 jours
pour que nouvelles routines devienne une
habitude spontanée personnellement je
fais ma méditation le matin quasiment
après le réveil je vous conseille ce
moment là principalement parce que vous
n'avez pas être parasité par quoi que ce
soit à la condition sinequanone n'est
quand même si tu me regardes que vous
n'ayez pas encore mis le nez dans votre
portable c'est à dire voici comment je
vous propose d'organiser votre routine
si vous avez laissé votre téléphone
allumé durant la nuit vous vous
réveillez vous le mettez en mode avion
vous mettez pas le nez deux dents vous
vous faites si vous voulez votre petit
déjeuner avant pour ce qui est enfin
vous pouvez aller à la salle de bains
moi personnellement je préfère méditer
quand je me suis lavé y en a qui
préfèrent faire savant vous recommande
de faire ça comme ça vous êtes
débarrassé des tâches un petit peu du
matin et vous vous mettez ensuite à
faire votre méditation avec
l'application petit bambou et une fois
et seulement une fois que vous aurez
fait la méditation vous pourrez
réellement allumez votre téléphone et
commencer à regarder vos notifications
et tout ce que vous voulez mais si vous
mettez ça plus tard dans votre journée
vous avez toujours être un petit peu
parasite eve avec ce que vous avez
encore à faire dans la journée ce qui
s'est rajouté etc
ça va être plus compliqué de trouver le
moment de méditer après il y en a qui
préfèrent le faire le soir en rentrant
chez eux ou avant de se coucher
bon j'ai juste peur moi qu'en faisant ça
quand je rentre fatigué j'ai c'est très
étrange à dire mais la flemme de méditer
alors que ce n'est que consacrer 10
minutes à moi-même dans la journée mais
personnellement je me méfie de moi même
pour faire ça donc je le fais le matin
c'est pour ça je vous recommande le
matin mais surtout trouver votre propre
rythme c'est ça qui est important
l'application petit bout en bout elle
est disponible sur l'iphone elle est
disponible sur android
évidemment vous avez le lien dans la
description il n'y a pas de code
particulier mais je voulais dit
il aiguille première méditation guidée
vous sont offertes donc essayez le comme
ça vous verrez que astuces numéro 4 5
c'est l'observation de ses émotions
j'ai dit 4,5 mais c'est parce que je
sais plus trop comment j'avais organisé
les astuces mais j'observe mes émotions
et je vois que ça ne me dérange pas on
parle souvent du non verbal sur la
chaîne à quel moment on observe le nôtre
à quel moment s'observe nous-mêmes et on
analyse nos propres micro expressions
quasiment mais en tout cas nos propres
émotions
la réponse jamais pourquoi je dis jamais
comme un mec bourré parce que je pensais
à la cité de la peur et odile deray
jamais like situe à la référence quand
vous ressortez une émotion qui autre que
la joie parce que la joie on s'en plaint
pas trop quand même
prenez le temps de l'analyser avant de
la subir les émotions on les subit elle
monte et on fait avec
néanmoins encore une fois on peut se
décentrer juste pour se poser quelques
questions simples pourquoi je ressens ça
qu'est ce que ça me fait est-ce que
c'est logique je ressens ça ou pas et
ensuite laissez la vivre et ne vous
jugez pas n'allez pas contre en fait le
problème d'aller contre ces émotions
c'est qu'on peut pas les soutes chez
après alors que si vous prenez le temps
de l'analyser vous pouvez aussi décider
de passer dans une autre émotion plus
positives par exemple avec la fatigue
avec le rythme que j'ai parfois ça
m'arrive de ne pas avoir envie de faire
quelque chose ou être simplement de
mauvaise humeur
sauf que avant de faire cette chose si
je dois absolument la faire je prends le
temps de l'analyser j'aime je me moquer
de moi en fait je vais moto foutent de
ma gueule mentalement et je veux prendre
le temps de switcher d'émotion et d'être
content simplement de faire ce que je
fais de me rappeler pourquoi en fait
c'est cool
et pourquoi tout va bien dans ma vie et
que c'est pas grave
en fait que j'ai une émotion négative je
me juge pas là dessus ça arrive à tout
le monde c'est normal c'est logique mais
maintenant il est temps de passer à
autre chose juste de rationaliser ce un
petit peu en prenant un peu de recul
ça permet vraiment de décider si on est
quelqu'un d'aigri si on est quelqu'un en
colère si on est quelqu'un qui raconte
du mal sur les autres ou si on est juste
content a pas forcément utiliser le mot
heureux mécontents n'hésitez pas à
utiliser ses astuces régulièrement au
début ce sera pas automatique mais à la
fin ça ne deviendra on prend soin
aujourd'hui de notre corps c'est quelque
chose que l'on sait qu'on met en avant
les mêmes des messages sous les pubs etc
mais il faut aussi prendre soin de son
mental l'un va pas sans l'autre
c'est d'une importance capitale vous le
savez vous suivez la chaîne et buffett
le vous avez vraiment tout à y gagner
merci encore une fois à petit bout en
bout d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo
n'oubliez pas que vous avez le lire dans
la description pour la télécharger
directement vous avez donc l'élu
première méditation guidée qui sont
gratuites n'hésitez pas en profiter pour
l'essayer de méditer au moins une fois
dix minutes
n'oubliez pas également de laisser un
legs si cette vidéo vous a plus de me
suivre sur instagram poursuivre les fun
fact et les jeux ici vous avez une vidéo
de basse et celle de la semaine dernière
la dernière tu es sorti ici c'est une
vidéo un peu concept un tacle in the
escape bien que j'avais fait pour le
million d'abonnés très cool aussi
à très bientôt ciao et loïc je crois que
cette blague n'a jamais été fait encore